many people across the country will be
struggling with their mental health with
lockdown meaning separation from loved
ones and potential anxiety about
returning to work we can speak now to
Paul farmer the chief executive of the
mental health charity mind very good to
see you this morning mr. farmer
how bad is it getting do we have any
idea of the effect that Kovach 19 and
indeed the lotto is having on the
nation's mental health yes where we are
concerned about an emerging mental
health crisis and in particular there
are three groups that we are paying
particular attention to first of all
people with existing mental health
problems where we know from our own
surveys that roughly two-thirds of
people with existing mental health
problems of reporting their mental
health is deteriorating secondly we're
concerns about those people our greatest
risk as a result of the kovat crisis
frontline workers people from black a
minority ethnic communities people may
be living in abusive households and we
know their mental health is at risk as
well and then finally of course as a
wider public we know that we've all been
asked to do things that are broadly
speaking not that good for our mental
health being separated from our loved
ones some of those protective factors
that we put in place to sustain our
mental health being removed so we do
have these three areas of concern which
I think all add up to a very significant
issue for our country's mental health
and as many people have perhaps at
taking news alluding to there has been a
focus on people's mental health
suffering through this process but as
you mentioned perhaps as many as one in
four of us had a pre-existing mental
health condition before corvid 19 came
along what has been the effect on the
access to mental health care provision
well I think the positive from the last
few years is the more people that be
more aware of their own mental health
and have sort out sort information and
support roughly a million people
downloading information from our website
in the last few weeks alone just to
think about how they look after their
mental house
but we do seem to be in this slight
paradoxical situation where would be
many people are reporting deteriorating
mental health but the NHS is reporting a
decline in numbers of referrals into the
mental health system so we do think it's
incredibly important to stress that
mental health services aren't very much
open for people to approach them there
is currently the capacity in there but
we are also in the middle of rebuilding
mental health services from a position
where really there was far too little
investment over a very long period of
time into building services as a fit for
the whole of all of us all up our whole
population and we're still on a journey
towards that so we think that services
are going to come under considerable
pressure and over the next few months
and it's absolutely vital that
appropriate action is taken now to put
in place the resources and the support
that's needed to cope with what's likely
to be quite a significant mental health
surge over the course of the next few
months we've been discussing on the show
this morning the idea that many children
may be going back to school on the 1st
of June and the lack of contact that
young people have been having with their
peers their social groups and all the
rest of it is bound to be having an
effect in your mind would it be better
for children to be back in schools
sooner rather than later because of that
mental health aspect well that's a
decision for government and local
authorities to make about on the grounds
of safety but from a mental health point
of view we know that young people are
missing their friends they're missing
the peer contact that they have
fortunately many are able to keep up
with their friends through social media
routes but I think the the quicker we
can get young people back into their
kind of normal cycle of activity the
better that will be for their mental
health looking after with support from
parents and teachers and professionals
and I think we're particularly wanting
to make sure that young people who do
have mental health problems are able to
access that help and support as quickly
as possible and the really effective
referral routes are put in place to make
sure that people can read
the mental health support they need
let's not forget that the number of
young people with mental health problems
was already on the rise before the kovat
crisis increasing from roughly 1 in 10
young people to now 1 in 80 on people
and so there's a real need to make sure
that we are highlighting the importance
of young people who may be developing
mental health problems getting access to
that help and if it's not possible to do
that through schools then other
mechanisms need to be found to make sure
those referrals are able to take place
so that young people get the help they
need particularly and I think we're
particularly concerned about young
people with emerging eating disorders
and increasing we've heard increasing
levels of anxiety and indeed loneliness
amongst young people and well many of us
myself included have had our wobbles and
our struggles and if people want more
information they can head straight to
mines website err but for now Paul
Farmer chief executive of the mental
health charity mind thank you so much
for joining us